so what we have depicted here is a
reaction I have a beaker in that Beaker
I have molecules I have these purple
molecules I also have these blue ones
and if I were to just leave this Beaker
at room temperature in my laboratory
nothing is going to happen they aren't
these molecules aren't going to react
with each other but then if I add energy
to this if I were to heat it up then I
can get it to react and so that's what
we have over here the energy is used to
break these bonds and then the bonds can
reform to form different molecules so we
have a reaction here here the reactants
here are the products and I'm also going
to assume that as these bonds as these
new bonds form it also releases energy
and what we're going to think about in
this video is whether the energy that is
released from this reaction is greater
than or less than than the energy that
we put into it and depending on the
answer to that we would label this is
either an endothermic or an exothermic
reaction so let's think about this a
little bit more so if you have a system
and you might say what's a system well a
system is really just a fancy way of
saying the thing that you are focused on
and you can Define that system in any
which way here we will call our system
this Beaker that has the solution inside
of it so our system is going to include
that but it's not going to include the
outside the burner that we're using to
create the heat it's just that Beaker so
this is the system in either situation
and then we could also label the things
outside the system we could call that
the surroundings hopefully that's a an
intuitive thing to call it and when we
light the flame underneath this Beaker
we're transferring energy from the
surroundings into the system the law of
conservation of energy which is also
known as the first law of thermodynamics
tells us that energy can neither be
created nor destroyed so for getting
energy into a system it has to come from
someplace in this situation the energy
is coming from our surroundings but as
we know we're not just putting energy
into the system when these new bonds are
formed it's also releasing energy in a
situation where it's releasing less
energy than was put in I'll do that with
a less wide Arrow like this this we
would call an n endothermic reaction
even though some is being released on a
net basis you're putting more in than
you actually getting out now if you had
it the other way around where if you had
your system here and you're putting in a
certain amount of energy into the system
but you're getting a lot more energy out
of the system I'll do that as a big
Arrow like this that's that's an arrow
not that's not a house if you have a big
Arrow like this well now this we would
call an
exothermic
exothermic reaction let me box these off
so that we don't get confused now we can
also understand this in terms of
potential energy and how the reaction
progresses so on the horizontal axis
we'll call this reaction progress
reaction
progress and then the vertical axis is
potential energy now our system before
we start heating it up our system is
going to be at some potential energy and
maybe it's just happy right there but
then we start putting energy into the
system we're doing this right over here
by lighting that burner under it so as
we put energy into the system the
potential energy goes up and that energy
is used to essentially break the bonds
of these reactants and then once those
molecular parts are all free of each
other they can now reform new bonds and
if if we're in an exothermic reaction
those new bonds are going to be at a
lower potential energy than the original
bonds of the reactants so one way to
think about it here is at this phase we
are putting in energy this is the energy
we're putting into the system and you
can calculate it by thinking about this
arrow and then once those molecular
Parts reform you are releasing energy
and so you could think of that height as
the release of energy and if you thought
about what the net energy that gets
released is well that's going to be the
difference between the potential energy
as you're entering into the reaction and
then your final potential energy so this
distance right over here is the net
energy and in this case it is the net
energy that has actually been released
from the reaction so this right over
here is an exothermic reaction you might
be wondering well what would an
endothermic reaction look like Well in
that situation and I'll just draw it
really fast it would have the same
labels on the chart you would be putting
energy in so let's say you have some
molecules energy in to break those bonds
the bonds are broken and now things
reform but they get to a higher
potential energy than you were before so
here we're putting in a lot of energy
but then when those bonds when we have
new bonds
forming that's not quite as much as the
energy that we put in and so there's a
amount that we put in the net amount
that we put in is going to be the
difference between that and that it's
going to be this height right over here
so this is exothermic and this is
endothermic right over here